this is special agent anthony amoroso jr
federal bureau of investigation
today's date is january 7 1980
location the townhouse in washington dc
the man in this video is undercover fbi
agent anthony armoroso and in 1980 he
was about to make the biggest bust of
his career
this is john gendredz by the time agent
omarosa took this video john had been a
member of the us house of
representatives for nearly five years he
was a congressman but by the time his
meeting with the undercover fbi agent
was over he had also just made a choice
that would cost him his life
you see in 1980 congressman john
generetz was feeling a little down on
his look as a democratic representative
he was only making around sixty thousand
dollars a year and for a single guy in
his twenties that may have been enough
but jon was 44 years old
four years earlier he had married a
playboy model named rita carpenter but
if he wanted to keep this playboy model
as his wife he was gonna need a little
extra bread so something was gonna have
to change about his income
luckily congressman john had just heard
about a new lucrative business
proposition from a wealthy arab chic the
1970s oil crisis had just passed so
everyone knew these arab oil guys had
big money and here was an opportunity to
take some of that money for himself and
it was simple all he had to do was find
a way to slip a law past congress that
would allow the sheik to move to america
permanently not a big deal right and in
exchange the sheik would pay him a
hundred thousand dollars or around three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
today's money he would get fifty
thousand dollars as soon as he accepted
the deal and another fifty thousand
dollars once the bill was passed how
hard could it be it was just a tiny bit
of corruption and it was just too good
to pass up
this one deal could earn john nearly two
years worth of his salary in just a few
months and of course once he proved
himself he was sure the sheik would use
him again
plus jon rather liked the throw of doing
something illegal so when the sheik's
man asked him if he was sure he famously
replied quotes i've got larceny in my
blood i'll take the money in a god
minute end quote
to john it was a done deal
a few days after his meeting he met with
the sheik's representative who handed
him a package filled with fifty thousand
dollars in cash it was almost too good
to be true in his hands jon held a full
year salary and that was just the first
of many more to come
but little did john know there was no
chic there wasn't any oil business or
millions of dollars on the table either
it was all a cover a story created by
the fbi to catch some of america's most
corrupt politicians in the act and
everything jon has said and agreed to it
had been all caught on tape but john
wasn't alone he was just one of 19
government officials and employees
brought down by operation app scam one
of the biggest and most shocking things
in fbi history and the best thing about
it when app scam started no one had any
idea how important this operation would
become you see operation app scam had
actually started as a small sting to
catch art thieves but in just a few
short months it had morphed into
something entirely different and it all
started with an fbi agent making a deal
with a convicted con man
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime on my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
instagram jaketran and you're
automatically entered a few of you have
won already watch out for fake accounts
i will never message you asking for
money or to invest and this is operation
app scam one of the largest political
corruption bus in u.s history
with inflation higher than it's ever
been in our lifetime everything is more
expensive and our dollars don't go as
far as they did before that's why it's
more important than ever to save as much
money as you can right now and one way
to save money that you may not know
about is that you can actually contact
your phone carrier or your utilities and
negotiate with them to lower your bills
yes you can actually do this but it
takes forever it's a real hassle and you
actually have to negotiate with someone
on the phone but what if you could have
someone do this for you at no cost to
you well you're in luck because that is
where true bill comes in true build is
an amazing all-in-one personal finance
app and one of their coolest features is
that they will actually negotiate your
bills down for you just select the bill
you want to lower take a photo of your
build or enter the information manually
and that is it truebill will get to work
negotiating your build down true bill
has an 85 success rate of lowering bills
and if they're successful you get to
decide how much of those savings you
want to pay true bill for their services
i usually choose 50 of whatever they
save me they also have a ton of other
features that's already saved me and 3.4
million other users over 100 million
dollars in counting my other favorite
feature of theirs is their subscription
tracker that lets you never pay for an
unwanted subscription again just
securely link your bank account and true
bill will instantly find and track your
subscriptions if there's one you want to
cancel just click cancel right in the
app and your true bill concierge will
cancel it for you without you ever
having to leave the app and this is just
a tip of the iceberg there's a ton of
other great features that are going to
save you a ton of money that i'm really
proud to promote
so what are you waiting for stop leaving
money on the table by pausing the video
and going to truebuild.com jake with the
link below that's true beau.com jake
with the link below so they know i sent
you thanks to trubil for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
it was the height of the 70s and mel
weinberg was having the time of his life
with the fbi too busy investigating
watergate mel had been scamming people
every chance he got insurance fraud
investment scams you name it mel was in
on it and with all that money from his
shady businesses a guy like mel just
couldn't resist living it up what was
your average annual income for the five
years let's say prior to absent
well i would say i must average the
company i have much to average of half a
million to a mere a year or more this is
london investors that's correct and your
deal basically was getting front money
from people that you were going to
deliver loans to except you never
delivered the loan that's correct in
true mobster style he split his time
between his wife and his mistress
jetting from europe to south america to
the caribbean living a life of luxury
and always keeping an eye out for his
next big job until he got caught like
every high value scammer in history mel
eventually found himself face to face
with the fbi but instead of sending him
off to rot in jail for a decade fbi
agent john good came to him with an
offer he just couldn't refuse agent good
was looking for the big fish even bigger
than mel weinberg forget small time con
men good wanted to break into the world
of stolen art but to do that he needed
someone with insider knowledge someone
with a strong reputation as a master
criminal someone no one would ever
expect worked for the fbi and that's
where mel came in in exchange for
probation a salary and the possibility
of bonuses instead of jail time agent
good wanted mel weinberg to help him set
up an undercover operation to bus new
york's stolen art industry wide open and
so operation abscam was born
[Music]
at first operation appscam was nothing
more than a small time sting targeting
the art thieves of the new york
underworld here's how it worked
the fbi registered a company called
abdul enterprises on long island that's
where the name abscam came from
this company was supposedly owned by a
super-rich arab sheik who wanted to
invest millions of his oil money in
buying valuable art
and unlike american collectors this arab
businessman didn't care if the art was
stolen he only cared that it was
valuable
what was mel weinberg's role in all of
this well mel did what mel knew best he
played the con man the sleazy shady
middle man who was in it for the money
and nothing more when someone with as
bad a reputation as mel came around
introducing an arab sheik no one would
ever dream the fbi had anything to do
with it and if anyone had the sense to
dig deeper into abdul enterprises the
fbi had already recruited a bank to
confirm the sheik's wealth
and in just a few months operation
appscam had become a massive success
with the part lebanese fbi agent playing
the part of the billionaire chic the fbi
recovered two stolen art pieces worth a
combined 1 million dollars
but it didn't end there you see in the
criminal underworld news of ultra
wealthy foreigners with millions to blow
spreads fast and soon mel wasn't out
looking for criminals to trap anymore
they were coming to him
we put the
big honeypot out there and all the flies
came to us
from art thieves the fbi moved on to
criminals selling fake stocks and bonds
this time they prevented the sale of
almost 600 million dollars in fake
securities and that's where things got
interesting because one of the main guys
selling those fake bonds william
rosenberg came to mel with a new
business plan
casinos in atlantic city
according to william the mayor of camden
angelo erichetti was as dirty as they
came and he would happily take a bribe
in exchange for issuing abdul
enterprises and atlantic city gambling
license
if you didn't know because of how
regulated and profitable the gambling
industry is getting a gambling license
is super hard and they are as good as
gold this was bigger than anything mel
or agent good could ever have imagined
hot on the scent of political corruption
operation abscam was on the verge of its
biggest bust yet
[Music]
in the immortal words of the mayor of
camden angelo erichetti quote i'll give
you atlantic city without me you do
nothing end quote
that's exactly what mayor erichetti
promised to do
according to erichetti he had a lot of
influence with new jersey's casino
control commission for the right price
he could roll out the red carpet for the
sheik to open his own casino in the
heart of atlantic city edichetti's
position as mayor made him the biggest
fish operation apps game had targeted so
far so before they could move forward
mel and the fbi would have to make sure
they could build an airtight case
and the only way to do that get it all
on camera of course
they wired every corner of the abdul
enterprise offices with mics and cameras
so when mayor erchetti arrived in
december 1978 ready to seal the deal and
receive the first installment of what
was supposed to be a four hundred
thousand dollar bribe the fbi was ready
for him erichetti was caught red-handed
taking a 25 000 bribe from a foreign
national but they didn't want to arrest
him yet after his first taste of arab
riches edichetti immediately started
recommending his dirty bodies in the
government for the sheik to do business
with and the first guy on his list a u.s
congressman in washington dc with the
power to give the sheik a golden ticket
unconditional asylum in america
agent good and mel weinberg found
themselves heading deeper into the
rabbit hole of political corruption and
with someone literally offering to
change america's laws in exchange for a
little cash there was no way operation
appscan was putting the brakes on now
and that brings us to our guy
congressman john general down on his
luck and in desperate need of a good
payday john didn't think twice about
taking the bribe
and it didn't end with him
every time the sheik and his
representatives would offer a politician
a bribe another congressman or
representative would come out of the
woodwork desperate for his share of the
oil money
eventually the agents running operation
appscam were meeting government
officials everywhere from luxury yachts
to fake offices in florida
and in each of these locations the fbi
set up a network of cameras and bugs to
record every last word
everyone these congressmen were told one
thing only if you can do us a favor for
these arabs all right that you'll
sponsor them we're willing to pay if you
can't do it then we don't want to pay it
most of the time these officials just
happily offered everything they had from
citizenship to government contracts and
natural resource rights
in the end seven high-level government
representatives and more than a dozen
other corrupt officials were caught
red-handed taking bribes in exchange for
political favors
and abscam's biggest prize
senator harrison williams
at first he refused the bribe but after
a few months he reconsidered and
actually came back to the sheik with a
counteroffer he would help abdul
enterprises get the government contract
to buy titanium from a mine in virginia
and in exchange he would secretly take
his share of 18 of the profit the sheik
said he would invest 100 million dollars
in the deal which meant a massive
hypothetical payday for senator williams
except that payday never came
[Music]
the fbi agents wrapping up the
undercover phase of something called
operation abscam it's what one u.s
attorney calls the biggest political
scandal in this country since watergate
last night a federal jury convicted the
61-year-old senator williams is the
seventh member of congress convicted on
abscam charges the abscam trials have
resulted in the conviction of six
congressmen one mayor and sundry others
and more indictments are expected when
news of abscam finally leaked to the
press in 1981 agent good had everything
he needed to take the corrupt officials
down thankfully not all the politicians
operation appscam targeted had wanted to
play ball
just like the other representatives
senator larry pressler was also
approached and asked for a favor in
exchange for a bribe
to the fbi's surprise pressler almost
immediately told the sheik what he was
suggesting was illegal
as soon as the meeting ended pressler
actually reported what had happened to
the fbi not once dreaming that they had
known about it all along
it is known that at least one senator
republican larry pressler of south
dakota rejected a suggestion from two
men posing as businessmen who said it
would be easy to quickly very quickly
raise between 50 and 100 000 for his
campaign pressler who at the time of the
meeting last november was a candidate
for the republican presidential
nomination said he told the two not once
but three times that what they were
talking about was illegal and after a
few minutes conversation left the house
with video evidence of the government
officials accepting bribes it's no
surprise most of the cases were open and
shut
of the seven government officials taken
to court all seven were convicted and
sentenced to a mix of jail time
probation and fines
u.s senator harrison a williams three
years in jail
u.s representative frank thompson two
years in jail
u.s representative john general two
years in jail
u.s representative raymond lederer three
years in jail
u.s representative michael ozzie myers
three years in jail
u.s representative john m murphy three
years in jail
u.s representative richard kelly 18
months in jail their lawyers tried
accusing the fbi of entrapment of
creating a crime for the sole reason of
catching a politician doing something he
wasn't supposed to but in the end even
the judges overseeing the cases had to
side with the jury
a government official stuffing an
envelope filled with cash in his pocket
was just too compelling too hard to
ignore
during his two years of work in
operation appscam informant mel weinberg
received nearly a hundred fifty thousand
dollars from the fbi
mel weinberg why did you cooperate with
the fbi help the fbi to stage abscam was
it was it fear was it patriotism or was
it just another way to make a buck
strictly for the money i went and
started after the case he tried his hand
at private investigation before retiring
in 1994
he always loved watching the copies of
the app scam recordings he was allowed
to take with him
mel passed away in 2018. agent john good
retired from the fbi in 1986.
he also opened his own private
investigation firm in new york
agent good passed away in 2016.
like mel and agent good
most of the politicians that were
involved in abscam are now dead but
operation appscam lives on as one of the
fbi's most shocking controversial and
successful investigations to ever be
made public
so one of my favorite movies of all time
is american hustle all-star cast that
has money power crime in it while being
super funny at the same time and it was
loosely based on this operation so
really happy i finally got to make a
video on this if you're new here my name
is jake and this is one of the biggest
channels on youtube for documentaries on
money power war and crime so if you
enjoyed this one we make multiple videos
just like this every single week for
free so click that subscribe button
below remember if you want a chance to
win a thousand dollars you can follow me
on instagram jake tran if you use
facebook and you want shorter versions
of these videos you can follow me on
there we might be doing giveaways over
there too nothing yet but that's gonna
wrap it up thank you so much for
watching stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you